hi I'm grace I'm mamrie and together we
have a show called this might get on
YouTube and today we're doing this we're
giving people haircuts because these
hands were made to make people beautiful
[Music]
okay Emily Emily grace welcome what was
your name again you know Rahul what are
you looking for today Rahul do you have
any major life events coming up right
have a big first date this week yeah it
could be like a maker break I am meeting
my girlfriend's parents in a few days
no pressure anything okay I'm getting
married don't say that don't don't don't
don't put on like in general it's a life
goal or it's happening soon it's
happening okay you have a good style
already a great face I would like to
look cooler though possible I think I
look cool nerdy you look nerdy no woman
if we look like giant thumbs what would
be an ideal scenario I feel like I
really liked a channel am I like Lord of
the Rings elf oh okay you want to look
like Arlanda blue this is tough to do
because your hair is so good
yeah it's like the opposite of a blank
canvas it's like you're telling us to
add accents to the Sistine Chapel so you
want us to clean up your edges I'm gonna
start in the back because if he's
looking at the back of your head or
she's looking at the back your head and
it's wrong then that means the dates
already a bit over okay here we go
oh my god ready wait I'll turn you
around so that you don't have to feel
the pressure okay here we go okay baby
here we go just a quick trim oh yeah
this is easy
we should dampen it right dampen the
edges and pin the edges this is just
water it's just water also I love that
on this morning oh God right my face
sorry I'm just gonna throw in some
braids you're gonna look very like
Coachella Westworld I'm gonna get in
there okay you're gonna do scissors I'm
just gonna trim off the very weight you
should you turn around so they can see
the trimming happen yeah yeah yeah
it's okay so hair gross we're not given
tattoos do you guys have a machine
honestly I think I'm doing a great job
yeah that looks great yeah whoa whoa
fairy dust if you had to describe him in
three words what would you say I would
say it nerdy funny and annoying Oh
honest honest that's good that you guys
gonna spend the rest of your life
together with someone you think is
annoying Oh does this have to come off
well you know I think Oh God that just
got louder for some reason here we go
very steady and beautiful I mean I think
that's looking good I mean I always do
this they're like yeah man you can get
in there with your own hands have you
ever played with color one that would
really pop on this is a yellow so my
inspiration for this is like the lines
on a road and how when it's like a
dashed line it's like come on over where
are you getting married oh my god I mean
literally becoming a jar Harry married
is it open bar is there a theme theme is
movies we both make a gif together so
we're doing like a red carpet what kind
of movies I'm gonna really Jersey
housewives this up right now there we go
that's yellow so I'm going for very like
90s clueless beats like insane clown
posse fan oh my god whoo you're like a
like a hipster clown I'm just really
trying to tease get a lot of volume you
have fantastic thick hair I'm so jealous
oh my god I have two hairs on my head
and I tease the hell out of them oh it's
very Sonic the Hedgehog oh whoa you're
kind of like Shark Boy or like Jimmy
Neutron if you went through a weird
Isis phase I think whoa whoa oh my god
you look like Kat Von D had a really
bratty teenage daughter this would be if
Sonic retired to Hawaii
and joined a rockabilly bands just like
look at a little strike down a column we
got cornrows we got it's at the
graduation song or the I think I'd
wedding I think thank you for being our
first customer she looks beautiful
Wow excessive and unnecessary so we call
our salon congratulations good luck with
your merge good luck with
happily-ever-after it'll never go wrong
now is it okay I like it okay yeah yeah
thank you so much good luck with the day
luck with your daughter Nayla wishing
you the best
it was hard and also exciting because I
really I mean wanted everyone to look
their best
yeah I think you know what I think are
like strength is yes getting in their
brains and really you know knowing the
scenario of how they need their hair
harsh I know the hair scenario right and
then also really upselling a really
shitty end product to someone I think is
a strong suit of ours totally again I'm
grace I'm mamrie check out this maquette
and thanks so much for watching buzzy
good bye
[Music]